so let's talk a little bit about
molecular solids so just as a little bit
of review we've talked about ionic
solids where ions form these lattices so
those might be the positive ions right
over there
and then you have your negative ions and
the negatives attracted to the positive
the positives attracted to the negative
and i'm just showing a two-dimensional
version of it but it forms a
three-dimensional
lattice so that's an ionic solid
we have also seen
metallic
solid
where you have metals that all
contribute some valence electrons to the
sea of electrons so what you end up
having is essentially these positive
cations
that are in this sea of electrons
and we've talked about those properties
very good at conducting electricity
malleable etc
now what we're going to do is talk about
what happens when you have
non-metals so the non-metals you can see
in yellow right over here also includes
hydrogen now of course noble gases are
also non-metals but they're not reactive
so we're going to talk about the
reactive non-metals they can form
molecules with each other for example
one iodine can bond to another iodine
with covalent bonds so you could have a
molecule like i2 you have things like
carbon dioxide each carbon can bond to
two oxygens these are each molecules
formed due to covalent bonds between
non-metals
now when we're talking about molecular
solids we're talking about putting a
bunch of these together so let's say
putting a bunch of iodine molecules
together and the intermolecular forces
at a sufficiently low temperature are
sufficient to hold together those
molecules as a solid
so what do i mean by that let's look at
a few examples
this right over here is a picture of
solid iodine and the way it's made up is
you have these iodine molecules now each
of these iodine molecules are formed by
a covalent bond between two iodine atoms
now the reason why it's a solid is
there's enough dispersion forces we
talked about these london dispersion
forces that are formed by temporary
dipoles inducing dipoles in neighboring
molecules for example just by random
chance for a moment you might have more
electrons on this end of this iodine
molecule creating a partially negative
charge and then that means that some of
the electrons on this end of this
neighboring iodine molecule might be
repulsed by that negative charge so it
forms a partially positive charge and so
you have a temporary dipole inducing a
dipole in a neighboring molecule and
then they'll be attracted to each other
and we've talked about that as london
dispersion forces and at a sufficiently
low temperature that can keep them all
together as a solid now it's important
to point out i keep saying sufficiently
low temperature because these molecular
solids because they are only held
together not by the covalent bonds the
covalent bonds hold together each of the
molecules but the molecules are held
together by these fairly weak dispersion
forces they tend to have relatively low
melting points for example solid iodine
right over here has a melting point
has a melting
point
of 103
degrees celsius and i know what you're
saying that's not that low that's higher
than the temperature at which water
boils it would be quite uncomfortable
for any of us to be experiencing 113.7
degrees celsius but this is relatively
low when you talk about solids think
about the temperatures it requires to
melt say table salt we've talked about
that think about the temperatures it
takes to melt iron there you're talking
about hundreds of degrees in certain
solids thousands of degrees celsius
this is much lower and so as a general
principle molecular solids tend to have
relatively low melting points now how
good do you think they're going to be as
conductors of electricity pause the
video and think about that
well in order to be conductors of
electricity somehow charge needs to move
through the solid and unlike metallic
solids you don't have the sea of
electrons that can just move around so
these tend to be bad conductors of
electricity
if you want to see another example of a
molecular solid
this right over here is solid carbon
dioxide often known as dry ice what you
see here is each of these molecules each
carbon is bonded to two oxygens and has
a double bond with each of those oxygens
these are covalent bonds that form each
of these molecules but what keeps all of
the molecules attracted to each other is
once again those dispersion forces and
these forces between the molecules are
so weak that solid carbon dioxide
doesn't even really melt it doesn't even
go to a liquid state if you heat it up
enough to overcome these intermolecular
forces these dispersion forces it will
sublime which means it goes directly
from a solid to a gas state and it does
that at a very low temperature it
sublimes at negative
78.5 degrees
celsius
and if you've ever handled dry ice which
i don't recommend you doing without
gloves because it will hurt your skin if
you do touch it i actually did that
recently at my son's birthday party we
were playing around with dry ice
you don't mess around with this thing
because it is so incredibly cold and at
that temperature it will go from a solid
not even it won't even melt to a liquid
state it will go straight to a gas state
now the last thing i want to do is think
about why different molecular solids
will have different melting points so
let's compare for example molecular
iodine to molecular chlorine each of
these can form molecular solids we
looked at iodine a few minutes ago which
of these would you think would form
molecular solids with higher melting
points pause the video and think about
that
well as we talked about it each of these
molecules they're formed by covalent
bonds between two atoms
and what keeps the solid together are
these dispersion forces and in earlier
videos when we first talked about
dispersion forces we talked about
temporary dipoles and induced dipoles
and they're more likely to form between
heavier atoms and molecules because they
have larger electron clouds and are more
polarizable so if you compare molecular
iodine to molecular chlorine you can see
that iodine is clearly made up of larger
atoms and is therefore a larger molecule
which is more polarizable so it's larger
which means it's more polarizable
generally speaking
polarizable
which means it has stronger generally
speaking dispersion forces stronger
dispersion forces
now just as a reminder these dispersion
forces are between molecules each
molecule has a covalent bond between two
iodines and then the dispersion forces
are between the molecules but because it
has stronger dispersion forces we would
expect that a molecular solid formed by
iodine is going to have a higher melting
point than a molecular solid formed by
chlorine and i actually do have the
numbers here so the melting point
of a molecular solid formed by iodine
we've already talked about that that's
113.7 degrees celsius while the melting
point of a molecular solid formed by
molecular chlorine has a melting point
of negative
101.5 degrees celsius which is very cold
and so iodine has a higher melting point
because of the stronger dispersion
forces
now as i said those dispersion forces
are still not that strong this is still
not that high of a temperature compared
to melting points of other types of
solids we have looked at in the past